Vsauce Kevin here and these three grains
of rice help explain why you are you
also the knife and jar represent a
hypothesis for human sacrifice we'll get
to that later let's start with you
you'll be the green rice you desire
things love respect money friends wisdom
a cool haircut Fame YouTube views shoes
a robust stamp collection
those ever-changing objects of desire
are the red rice and you just want those
things because you want them right you
know what you like it's your freewill to
decide what it is you desire
maybe not anthropological philosopher
Rene Girard didn't think so while
survival depends on satisfying
biological needs like hunger desires are
not innate we're not born wanting a
fancy car or the prettiest gown at the
ball desires manifest from imitating
other people the subject we imitate for
any given desire is called a model
that's the blue rice your mom is blue
rice your dad grandma Maggie Albert
Einstein Harry Potter is blue rice a
model can be a person close to you or
just a person you've read about and a
triangular desire relationship flows
from you imitating the model to receive
the desired object I want to be as
wealthy as Bill Gates I want to be as
funny as my aunt Maureen I want to be as
sexy as some sexy muscley hunk
why do I speak English why do you speak
your native language because you
imitated people who imitated people
because aside from crying imitating
people was the first thing you ever did
in your life infants are able to imitate
facial acts like sticking out their
tongues immediately after being born the
youngest infant tested successfully
imitated 42 minutes after leaving the
womb according to psychologists and
infant development researcher Andrew
meltzoff that suggests infants have an
inborn mapping between the perception
and production of human acts becoming
you starts by becoming someone else but
it's not just monkey-see monkey-do or
conditioning a dog to dance for oranges
we project our own internal experiences
onto others to come to an understanding
that those moving meat bags with
eyeballs are like me gaze following is a
nonverbal triangular communication
between subject model and object infants
are more likely to gaze follow mothers
whose eyes are open rather than closed
leading meltzoff to hypothesize that an
infant knows when it closes its eyes the
world goes dark so it must go dark for
mommy to no need to follow her closed
eyes when I know she's not actually
looking at anything humans are born
imitating and human culture evolved by
imitating neuro anthropologist Merlin
Donald says our mimetic culture of
imitation is the first definitively
human stage of development non-human
primates do learn in social settings but
it's an episodic culture meaning they
pay attention to the result of an action
and then figure out the method for
achieving that through trial and error
rather than duplicating the successful
mannerisms they observed imitation is
humanity's cultural zero
Point long before we developed fancy
words like cultural zero or point
according to Gerard human society
developed as people copied one another's
desires to the point of becoming rivals
if the object of desire is in limited
quantity whether its territory or a
girlfriend
the rivalry to obtain it eventually
leads to violence when the violence
spread to a point where society was at
risk of collapse everyone got together
and sacrificed a goat more or less the
scapegoat mechanism is the process by
which group hostility is transferred
onto a single victim and banishing this
victim restores unity to the group
illusionist James Warren visualizes this
phenomenon using a jar rice and a knife
imagine that each grain of rice is an
individual person as their matching
desires jobs love and wealth spread like
a virus they get closer and closer until
they're packed so tightly that rivalries
emerge and friends families and
neighbors turn into enemies violence is
inevitable with society at risk of
collapse someone in the group is
perceived as an outsider and is chosen
as the party responsible for the chaos
all hostility is turned on the scapegoat
and social order is restored by uniting
around the common cause of banishing it
from the group or delivering the
ultimate banishment
killing it Gerard believes scapegoating
explains how early human societies
developed in Rene Girard and myth
richard Golson details of myth from the
vendor people of South Africa the snake
God Python had two wives during a
drought the second wife was seen as a
major disruption and was blamed for the
drought and the suffering of the people
so she was killed her death triggered a
flood and the community was saved after
successfully uniting the group the
scapegoat is sanctified from their
sacrifices honoring the event became a
religious consecration sacrificing
humans and later animals like goats paid
tribute to the gods and the great
uniting scapegoat the word scapegoat
means a symbolic bearer of the sins of
the people during the Salem witch trials
occult magic was used as an imagined
differentiator to single out women as
witches who were then executed to
restore peace to the village
foreign-born queen of france Marie
Antoinette was scapegoated as the cause
of unrest during the French Revolution
and off went her head here's the problem
scapegoating can only provide a
temporary sense of contentment soon
enough rivalries flare up a new
scapegoat is chosen and exiled and the
cycle begins again people actually
become dependent on this cycle as
reflected in CP kavafis waiting for the
barbarians in the poem an entire
city-state joins together in solidarity
and bases their behaviors around the
impending danger posed by the barbarians
except the barbarians never arrived it
ends with confusion and now what's going
to happen to us without barbarians they
were those people a kind of solution
scapegoating happens at home in school
in online communities and on social
media it's an emergent property
resulting from mimetic desire leading to
memetic rivalry and ending in mimetic
violence an escape goat is chosen to
quell the crowd you can see its
underpinnings everywhere even disco in
1977 Saturday Night Fever catapulted
disco music into the mainstream and its
soundtrack became one of the top-selling
albums of all time
within two years cultural dynamics
ranging from sexual and racial
demographics to internal strife among
commercial artists led to disco becoming
a scapegoat for eroding musical values
and baseball's Chicago White Sox
capitalized on the hysteria they
promoted a disco demolition night that
featured crowd supply disco albums being
blown up during the middle of a
doubleheader more people United to
participate in the figurative death of
disco and to watch the actual baseball
games disco was symbolically banished to
appease the crowd the effectiveness of
the scapegoat mechanism is contingent
upon the group being unaware of its
presence and being convinced this
scapegoat is actually guilty by
recognizing a group scapegoating the
power of the mechanism is diminished and
the violence is revealed
however because we're mimetic creatures
because we imitate each other to the
point of contagion it takes active
defiance in the face of our very nature
to step away from the crowd and
acknowledge the hidden force in play
which is really hard to do it's hard to
stand out because it's lonely as Russian
novelist Fyodor Dostoevsky who himself
was exiled from his society wrote in
notes from underground I am alone and
they are everyone
[Music]
Dostoyevsky's books have been translated
into 170 languages people all over the
world can learn from his writings they
can learn from him his mimetic influence
spreads and survives in a way more
powerful than a genetic influence ever
could he had four kids but he has
millions of grains of green rice
[Music]
by watching this video part of you is
now me if you consider that all of the
information and imitation passed down
from generations has been absorbed and
then ingrained in you throughout your
life to develop you into you you realize
that in a general sense Dostoevsky was
wrong they are at everyone you are
everyon
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
the person who inspired me to make a
YouTube channel was probably Tim
Heidecker from Tim and Eric awesome show
great job his style was so accessible it
was just a guy being hilarious and being
weird and having his own unique sense of
style and comedy and it spoke to me on
such a personal level that is the first
time I considered to myself like hey I'd
like to do this - hey I'm Destin from
smarter every day believe it or not I'm
inspired to make videos because of my
children they are curious little people
that like to learn and I want to be the
exact same type of person and I want to
learn stuff so that they can watch
videos in the future of their dad
learning stuff I have looked up to Bret
Michaels since I was 13 years old just
being a fellow type one diabetic and he
influenced me just by inspired me and I
wanted to take that and inspire others
and the best way that I knew how which
was through my artwork and through
charity I even keep his guitar in the
background of my videos for me guys like
John four Lakers and soldier knows best
really show that there was actually a
future and doing tech videos on YouTube
the person who inspired me to start
making YouTube videos is my friend and
was my roommate at the time nice Peter
made his channel and it looked like a
lot of fun so he helped me to make my
channel I'm getting me a leg up as well
as that time we got locked out of the
apartment he gave me a leg up to get
through the window because we can't do
it alone my high school teachers
definitely introduced me to science
communication but I think it was Derek
Muller and Henry Rice and by heart and
Charlie McDonald that are the ones that
inspired me to start my own YouTube
channel because I saw what they were
doing with this new platform and I was
like it's so cool like they've hijacked
this platform for cat videos but are
using it for science the person who
inspired me to start a YouTube channel
was natalie tran who makes community
channel she is hilarious she's a YouTube
og and best of all she is an awesome
person and I'm pleased now to be able to
call her a friend
my inspiration not just for making
youtube videos but for making
in general comes from being a kid as far
back as I remember I've always wanted to
make movies and the thing that inspired
that the most was was horror films
strangely enough when I was a kid a
young lad
my brother who is older would always
show me slasher films and horror movies
like right there teenth Halloween night
round Elm Street child's plays sleepaway
camp stuff like that and I love them
because they took you on an emotional
journey it was it was spooky it was
scary but it was funny and there was all
these different emotions that you felt
while watching and I loved the fact that
something something that I couldn't
interact was something that was a
passive experience I was just watching
could influence my emotions that much
and I wanted to be a part of that I
wanted to be able to do that to others
and that's what inspired me to make
movies to be able to take people on some
sort of experience some sort of
emotional journey and it just landed on
making them in a scientific I guess way
and that becomes the motivation for why
we're telling the stories we're going on
an informational journey and it just fit
I was inspired to make my first youtube
channel by Eric fence Leard
I've never met Eric Vince lair but he is
the guy who made the famous GI Joe PSA
parodies he took actual GI Joe cartoon
public service announcements and
overdubbed their voices with his own so
that they would say bizarre surreal
things and the strangeness of these
Clips made them viral I think they were
actually if not the first viral videos
on the Internet they were certainly in
that first batch that first generation
that showed the power of the Internet
and I had to get involved
it seemed so subversive and Punk to be
able to take a thing and subvert what it
meant and not need to have the blessing
of any gatekeepers it was just you and
then over time what I was putting out
there on the Internet evolved into what
it is today science communication like
and it enabled me to marry my interest
in in performing and and and art with
facts and knowledge and questions and
curiosity I think that line is always
blurry but man I really am thankful to
Eric fence ler for making things that
made me laugh and made me want to aspire
to make something similar my main
influence has always been my dad he's a
brilliant creator he builds guitars for
a living and now I build videos so
because of him I knew I always wanted to
have a life driven by creativity and one
of the creative projects I'm really
proud of is the Curiosity box this is a
subscription box filled with wondrous
items handpicked by Michael jaqen hi and
it's like getting Vsauce delivered right
to your door a portion of the proceeds
goes to Alzheimer's research so it's not
only good for your brain getting the
Curiosity Box is good for everyone's
brains
so check out curiosity box.com to
subscribe and be a part of a growing
community of the hyper curious your
support really means everything so
thanks